WITH US.
JOINING US NOW ON THE PHONE
FOR QUICK REACTION IS THE
GREAT ONE, LIFE, LIBERTY THE
LEVIN, WE CALL HIM MARK
LEVIN THE GREAT ONE IS WITH
US.
YOU KNOW, MARK, IT COMES
DOWN TO THE ARGUMENTS MADE
BY SCHUMER AND PELOSI.
I DON'T MEAN TO BE SARCASTIC
BUT IT LOOKED LIKE A
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE"
OPENING SKIT, BUT,
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING CHUCK
SCHUMER PARTICULAR BIDEN
SUPPORT OBAMA SUPPORT FOR A
WALL IN 2006 AND 2013.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THIS IS
A MANUFACTURED CRISIS AND
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THEY
ARE UPSET ABOUT THE DELAYED
CHECKS TO FURLOUGHED FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES WHICH I
AM SYMPATHETIC TOWARDS.
BUT THE PRESIDENT IS MAKING
THE CASE THAT WE HAVE
AMERICANS BEING VICTIMS OF
CRIME, HOMICIDE, SEXUAL
ASSAULT, OTHER VIOLENT
ASSAULTS THAT WE HAVE
TRAFFICKING AND THAT WE
HAVE -- THAT'S GOING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, DRUG
TRAFFICKING.
TO ME IT'S ABOUT LIFE AND
DEATH OR INCONVENIENCE.
THIS IS NOT MANUFACTURED.
YOU CAN'T TELL THE SON OF
OFFICER SINGH THAT IS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
THIS IS A REAL LIFE AND
DEATH SITUATION FOR MANY
AMERICAN FAMILIES AND I
WANTED TO GET YOUR REACTION
TO TONIGHT'S.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE
PRESIDENT GAVE AN
OUTSTANDING SPEECH.
IT WAS CONCISE.
IT WAS COMPASSIONATE AND
TRULY COMPASSIONATE.
HE PROVIDED THE CONTEXT BOTH
IN TERMS OF WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE BORDER, THE EXPENSE,
WHICH IS DEMINIMIS AND WHO
IS REALLY RESPONSIBLE.
LET'S KEEP A FEW THINGS IN
MIND WHEN YOU WATCH SCHUMER
AND PELOSI, THEY ARE
PATHOLOGICAL LIARS.
THEY HAVE BEEN IN CONGRESS
OVER HALF A CENTURY.
WHAT THE HELL HAVE THEY DONE
ABOUT THE BORDER?
NOTHING.
THEY ARE PART OF THE SCAM
ARTISTS.
THEY GET AMNESTY,
LEGALIZATION, CITIZENSHIP,
AND NEVER SECURE THE BORDER.
JUST SPEND BILLIONS AND
TRILLIONS MORE, MORE DEBT,
MORE DEFICITS ON THE
REDISTRIBUTION OF WEALTH, ON
$200 BILLION A YEAR ON
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
ONE MORE TIME THEY FOOLED
REAGAN.
THEY FOOLED BUSH 41.
THEY FOOLED BUSH 43.
BUT THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
FOOL DONALD TRUMP WHO HAS
GOT TOUGHER THAN PELOSI AND
SCHUMER.
LET ME POINT OUT A FEW
THINGS.
THESE TWO AND THE REST OF
THEM ARE NEVER FORCED TO
EXPLAIN THEIR FLIP FLOP
WHERE THEY WERE FOR BORDER
SECURITY.
THEY VOTED TO AUTHORIZE
WALLS.
THEY VOTED TO FUND SOME OF
THE WALLS AND NOW ALL OF THE
SUDDEN IT'S IMMORAL.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S IMMORAL?
WHEN EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT
THOSE GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES
WHO WILL BE TEMPORARILY
INCONVENIENCED, WHO WILL GET
THEIR MONEY BACK.
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT THE
UNSKILLED, LOW SKILLED
AMERICAN WORKER WHO HAS TO
COMPETE WITH PEOPLE FROM
GUATEMALA, FROM HONDURAS,
FROM MEXICO, FROM SOUTH OF
THE BORDER WHO COME INTO
THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT THE BIG
CORPORATIONS LIKE HEWLETT
PACKARD AND BOEING AND
DISNEY AND OTHERS.
WHERE PART OF THE SCAM
ARTIST OPERATION WHO WANT
ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT THE FACT
THAT DESTROYING OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, THESE
DEMOCRAT CITY SANCTUARY
CITIES, THESE DEMOCRAT STATE
SANCTUARY STATES WHERE THE
CITIZENS ARE TREATED AS
SECOND CLASS CITIZENS AND
THE TAXPAYERS HAVE TO COUGH
UP THE MONEY FOR, WHAT?
LET ME EXPLAIN WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
POWER.
DEMOCRAT PARTY POWER.
DEMOCRAT PARTY BEFORE
COUNTRY.
THERE IS APPEAR EXCELLENT
PIECE IN OF ALL PLACES THE
ATLANTIC.
A LEFT WING SITE WRITTEN BY
A GUY BY THE NAME OF PETER
BUCKHART A LIBERAL.
HE SAYS BETWEEN 2008 AND 26,
THE DEMOCRATS BECAME MORE
AND MORE CONFIDENT.
THE COUNTRY IS GROWING GAVE
THE PARTY ELECTORAL EDGE.
SO THEY SWITCHED.
SALON WHICH IS A LEFT WING
SITE.
THEY DECLARED AFTER OBAMA'S
2008 WIN IF THAT PATTERN
CONTINUES WITH THE LA TEEN LATIN
CONTINUES WITH THE LA TEEN LATIO
VOTE THE G.O.P. IS DOOMED 40
YEARS WANDERING INTO THE
DESSERT.
HE GOES ON TO EXPLAIN THIS
IS A LIBERAL AND LIBERAL
FIGHT.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING
ON.
NOTICE PELOSI AND SCHUMER
DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THE
AMERICAN WORKER.
NOTICE THEY DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT THE COMMUNITIES ON THE
BORDER THAT ARE SUFFERING.
NOTICE THEY NEVER TALK ABOUT
LAW AND ORDER BECAUSE THEY
HATED LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY NEVER TALK ABOUT THE
OVERWHELMING COST INVOLVED
IN HEALTHCARE.
THE OVERWHELMING COST
INVOLVED IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
LOCALITIES AND STATES, THEY
ARE BARELY REIMBURSED FOR
THIS.
WE, THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER,
THE AMERICAN CITIZEN, WE
TAKE IT IN THE NECK.
ONE OTHER THING, THE
DEMOCRAT PLATFORM IN 2008,
READ IT.
HOLD ON NOW, THE DEMOCRAT
PLATFORM IN 2008, BASICALLY
SUPPORTS VIRTUALLY
EVERYTHING THE REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES SAID TODAY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVEN'T
CHANGED.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HASN'T
THE DEMOCRATS FOR POLITICAL
REASONS AND POWER REASONS
THEY HAVE CHANGED AND THEY
WANT TO DRAG US ALL OFF THE
CLIFF WITH THEM.
>> Sean: MARK, THAT'S A
GREAT POINT AND WE PLAYED
THEIR PAST STATEMENTS MANY
TIMES ON THIS PROGRAM.
I KNOW YOU PLAYED IT ON YOUR
RADIO SHOW ON LIFE, LIBERTY
AND LEVIN.
I WANT TO GET TO THE ISSUE
OF LEGALITY.
I SAW A POST THAT YOU MADE
AND THAT IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT AS THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF HAS A
RIGHT TO DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY WHICH WOULD
THEREFORE GIVE HIP THE
FUNDS.
OBVIOUSLY END UP IN THE
COURTS AND GO JUDGE SHOPPING
AND PUT IN A COURT IN
CALIFORNIA SO IT WOULD GO TO
THE NINTH CIRCUIT.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
LEGALITY OF THAT AND ALSO,
AS THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF,
CONSTITUTIONALLY, THIS IS
YOUR WHEEL HOUSE, WOULDN'T
HE HAVE THE ABILITY TO SAY
THAT THIS IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE AND AS SUCH
BE ABLE TO APPROPRIATE FUNDS
FROM THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
AS WELL.
DOES HE HAVE OTHER OPTIONS
HERE?
>> AS USUAL, IT'S LEFT TO ME
TO STRAIGHTEN OUT ALL THE
PHONY EXPERTS ON CABLE AND
NETWORK TV WHO HAVE LAW
DEGREES AND PRETEND THEY
KNOW SOMETHING.
IT'S CALLED THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY ACT OF 1976.
>> Sean: MARK, I AGREE.
>> BASICALLY CONGRESS PASSED
THIS TO TIGHTEN AND LIMIT
WHAT A PRESIDENT COULD DO
UNILATERALLY THERE IS A
PROVISION IN THE STATUTE.
IT'S A STATUTE.
SO IT'S NOT THE PRESIDENT
ACTING UNCONSTITUTIONALLY.
AND IN THIS STATUTE IF
CONGRESS WANTS TO REVERSE OR
HALT WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING UNILATERALLY, IT TAKES
A JOINT RESOLUTION OF THE
HOUSE AND SENATE, A MAJORITY
VOTE.
THERE IS A CHECK.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, THESE POWERS
ESSENTIALLY IN DIFFERENT
ITERATIONS IN THE PAST,
DIFFERENT LAWS IN.
>> Sean: TWO 20 SECONDS,
MARK.
>> GO BACK BEFORE ABRAHAM
LINCOLN THEY HAVE BEEN
EXERCISED MULTIPLE TIMES:
EXERCISED BY GEORGE W. BUSH.
>> Sean: MARK, WE HAVE TO